y cientos de contenedores volcados
sobresalían del agua en una carretera
inundada después de días de fuertes
lluvias que provocaron inundaciones
masivas en la ciudad sudafricana de
durban muchos camioneros que transitaban
por el puerto más grande del país dicen
que casi quedaron atrapados dentro de
sus vehículos cuando el agua subió de
repente durante la noche
alrededor de las tres de la madrugada
sentí que el camión temblaba y pensé que
tal vez algo lo había golpeado pero
cuando traté de abrir la cortina vi que
el nivel de agua estaba muy alto traté
de encender el camión y después de
algunos intentos pude alejarme y tuviese
atún en toda la provincia de
kwazulu-natal las inundaciones y los
deslizamientos de tierra causaron
estragos y devastación las autoridades
esperan que las cifras de fallecidos
aumenten a medida que comiencen las
operaciones de rescate carreteras
enteras fueron destruidas y miles de
casas dañadas varias centrales
eléctricas se inundaron cortando el
servicio en algunas partes de la región
cientos de residentes quedaron varados y
sin poder comunicarse con el centro de
llamadas de emergencia pues se
encontraba colapsado aquellos que
lograron salir dicen que perdieron todas
sus posesiones
a los 92 no tengo adónde ir no tengo
casa no tengo nada la situación está muy
mal no sé en dónde vamos a dormir ahora
con tu explica la agencia de gestión de
desastres de la región instó a las
personas que residen en áreas bajas a
mudarse a terrenos más altos ya que se
esperan más lluvias para los próximos
días